like what like what one critique you got
for each one of these ladies okay for
you uh just more submissive
um you're very you're very vocal which
is there's no problem but it's
definitely gonna hinder you in the
dating field right because a lot of men
like a woman that they can
um you know be the more dominant figure
in their life for
um you that's not what I'm looking for
in the middle exactly Katie Katie Katie
I'm sorry I didn't know you're it's okay
my name's Katie I think you just need to
be uh more realistic there's there's no
problem I I respect that you uh have God
in your life and all things like that
but you just gotta uh come to terms with
like reality is the fact that
um if somebody like I feel like you're
argumentative right because you you
don't look at things for what they are
you look at things for what you want
them to be right so like earlier
whenever we mentioned uh you mentioned
the weight right and you're like that's
misogynist right but then you change it
to that's fat phobia right so I feel
like you just want to like cause an
argument and you just want to disagree
sometimes you just need to be more
open-minded and listen to people right
because you made some good points
sometimes I like you me you uh stated
something and you had the statistics
behind it I was like oh that makes sense
I never knew anything about that he even
he even agreed he's like I just found
out about that I forget exactly what it
was but you're like yeah I think yeah
yeah I didn't know anything about that
right and I just sat here I'm like
shaking my head like oh that's something
new I learned sometimes you just need to
do that without like ad living and
things like that because that's kind of
like uh unattractive you
um
like that ad living uh exactly you
didn't do anything particular that I
like I didn't pay it you didn't
interject or anything like that you like
particularly if I were just you I would
just be like yeah continue dating do
what you want just be realistic yeah
you've been realistic so I don't have
anything major for you cool about what
about you Pearl
um
okay
what was the original question like just
one critique for them to help them get
into relationship because this is a
dating show you know one critique to
help them get into a relationship
um
you're very pleasant
um you're actually very easy to talk to
too I think I think guys probably like
that yeah I don't know but thank you I
appreciate it as well I would I would
say
for you do you approach guys
that you like yeah okay then I have
nothing I was like yes I do I was a man
I'm literally look yeah I do okay I'll
shoot my shot he'll shoot me you shoot
your shot I'm a big believer in like
women should shoot their shots like
because I feel like a lot of times we'll
complain about not getting something but
if you go after it okay hey hey my girl
gave me uh her number I didn't yeah yeah
like
um
you're a bit rude so I'd say be less
rude
um I'll try my hardest all right I think
you kind of like to argue and I I feel
like men yeah yeah yeah okay
um you're you're pretty Pleasant you
know um but I think you also like to
argue
um I I think you probably shouldn't tell
men that you have multiple partners I
wouldn't say that publicly
unless you just want to State it with
that's her yeah I just think like girls
that's gonna like um a lot of guys that
might take you serious I think probably
wouldn't if you tell them that oh yeah
born again virgin
um I I wouldn't I wouldn't do that
um I don't even think you'd like the
guys that are willing to do that and
because I've seen a lot of assumptions
no it's just like I've been in a lot of
different churches and I've just seen
the way like church culture operates and
I just feel like it keeps women single
okay thank you for sharing your opinion
yeah that's good well don't be so rude
now the girls get to go though like now
y'all get to say the oscares because
because I mean all these people were
single too so you get to help them get
into a relationship maybe if you got
some good advice we're going to start
with you this time okay okay I forget
that everyone in this room is single
single
um I will start with pearl
um one great thing I think about you is
that you you have a lot of it seems as
if you have a lot of World Experience so
I admire that about you
um you know and I feel like it's it's
the point of this is to give a critique
about someone yes I feel bad giving I
can take it I can take it no and that's
not the issue because I know you can you
are a very strong woman and I do
appreciate that about you that's I I
admire that about you honestly
um and you don't take no [ __ ] that's
very admirable
um and but I feel bad giving critiques
about about someone that I don't know I
don't know you guys I'm only going on
don't be nice now okay it's just based
off what we've learned about each other
yeah I'll take it with a grandpa it's
okay you can
um
dating wait do you like men or women
here we go
I like I like men okay I'm just asking
maybe one of you guys I don't know no
point at me now don't point at me I'm
saying that sometimes I don't know why
I like Mad Men okay that's cool
oh okay gotcha you like older men
yeah yeah I mean that I mean I'm 25 so
like up to 45 maybe
um
and then okay I have I have a more of a
question then because again with this
from what I understand from the one
video that I saw you know you're
entering now into that age where you're
gonna be not fertile you're not going to
be desirable how does that make you feel
oh I mean it definitely like how do I
put it it makes you like think about
things a little bit more seriously are
you in a rush to find a man to like are
you trying to commit yeah I want to get
married okay yeah I do I I'd like to get
married in the next couple years
and so what will happen is so are you
trying to marry someone within the red
pill movement
no I don't really I mean if he's not red
pill I'll red pillow
so what does that mean exactly then like
pull them over to her yeah so then
you're okay with him leaving you because
you're not young anymore
um that's not what the red pill teaches
what does it teach it's basically like
um
guys your experiences to men are
valuable to them if you experience them
with them so like if a guy like a guy
kind of explained this to me like if he
meets his wife at 21 like in his eyes
she'll forever be 21. and maybe that's
like some guys will be like oh that's
[ __ ] but like I think like men build
like they love through loyalty and the
longer you've been with someone he
appreciates the Loyalty but it's not
valuable to someone else so if I come
out I'm 25 now if I come at 35 then it's
like it's not valuable to the next guy
that makes sense my concern my concern
is people are change over time I'm
definitely very different from when I
was 25. I've I've done a lot of therapy
I've like I've grown so much and so much
experience I've had and I feel like a
lot of people if they get from my
experience I've noticed that people that
get married so young once they get older
and they have a lot more experience they
end up getting divorced and that's my I
think that's my concern in in with you
is that you are in this belief you're
you're hanging around all these men that
are valuing youth so much and my concern
is I don't want the women out there
watching this to be thinking oh [ __ ] my
my worth my value is decreasing over
time I think if anything women's worth
is increasing over time because of all
the experience that we've had but I
think there's a difference between your
personal value like your value as a
person and your value to men
and it's not it's not a fun reality but
we can look at dating app data anecdotal
data or just looking at people on the
extremes like the men with the most
options who do they date men tend to
like younger women and youth is valuable
to men because that means you can bear
them children like I personally I want
to have like five kids I'm trying to I'm
trying to have a basketball team out
here and like I can't do that in 10
years I'm so glad I'm a cougar that's
all I gotta say I love me the young guys
so your critique is that I might get
married too young
my it's not really a critique it's more
of a concern I'm concerned that I I hope
I only want the best for everyone and I
hope that you're able to find someone
that will still
valuable value and worship you even
after your prime childbearing age okay
well hopefully I'll have you know buried
a couple kids for him as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible